I am
all these construction sites
[Music]
only a few years more
miracle gas
are used both to make them do a job,
that is, to get to food I have to work
hard because working
is good for their minds and
their well-being and  then they also serve a bit
for refreshment in these sultry days
it will be nice to smaller at a
time that one just because the
survival of the primate species
excuse breeding is manners and in
general the environmental enrichments
must not be done in a systematic way
always the same because otherwise they
become  boring because if you know
what you are expecting, it no longer attracts you
and Rome becomes boring